bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo
traditionnels comme noël enfin pour ceux
qui fêtent noël tous les ans je vous
fais un petit récapitulatif des films
que j'ai aimés pendant l'année et sommes
partis pour les films de l'année 2000 21
qui sont encore une fois un peu moins
nombreux que mon nombre habituel le pré
pandémie mais j'en ai quand même fait un
petit peu plus qu'en 2020 et j'ai vu des
bonnes choses j'ai sélectionné neuf
films parce que j'aurais pas envie de
parler de films dont j'avais bordé par
les ayants l'a9 qui m'ont vraiment plu
ou qui avait des défauts mais dont
j'adore vous parlez quand même donc
c'est parti je vous parle de ses films
et puis après en fin de vidéo je vous
raconte en petit peu ma vie fin le
reflet du lac de la chaîne tout ça le
premier film dont j'ai envie de parler
s'appelle de digues c'est un film qui
est sorti sur netflix uniquement à ma
connaissance et qui nous raconte
l'histoire de la découverte d'une tombe
du haut moyen-âge en angleterre dans les
années 40 qui est en fait un bateau
funéraire donc un truc assez monumentale
et je connaissais l'histoire de ce
bateau funéraire parce que ce que je
fais des études d'histoire et donc assez
vite en voyant film ce qui est bien fait
ça à l'air de parler de ça parce qu'au
début quand j'ai lancé j'avais pas lu le
résumé donc ça a été notre surprise pour
moi et c'est un film qui est très très
beau avec un très beau traitement des
couleurs des costumes qui rappelle bien
à l'époque et puis la campagne anglaise
ça fait un peu rêver tout ça et les
acteurs jouent très très bien parce
qu'évidemment c'est pas un film on voit
juste propre record creusé la terre
pendant deux heures par film qui parle
de personnes aussi de leurs de leur
rapport au passé de leur rapport à la
vie à la mort le personnage de la
propriétaire du terrain est très très
intéressant interprété par carlo
musicale mais on a aussi pas celui qui
creuse et qui n'est pas rare que l'homme
de formation et donc au bout d'un moment
si on commence avec flash et un petit
peu avec eux aimeraient archéologues
reconnue par la profession et qui
débarque en disant hé ben saada
intéressant ce que tu fais mon fils mon
boulot voilà donc c'est qui m'a
énormément plu est le deuxième film dont
j'ai envie de vous parler et prom a
single man qui est aussi un film avec
carey mulligan qui était dans nos digues
mais qui n'a rien à voir donc ce film se
passe aux etats-unis de nos jours on y
suit l'histoire d'une jeune femme un peu
perdue dans sa vie puisque on comprend
qu'elle a fait des études de médecine
mais maintenant elle bosse en tant que
vendeuse fait un boulot qui en dessous
de sa formation initiale et 7 filles
mènent une double vie puisque la nuit
elle sort dans les bars pour se
prétendre bourret est menacée slash
tabasser les mecs qui essayent de la
violer huit ans de l'occasion et c'est
bien avec très souvent visiblement donc
c'est un film de revanche assez puissant
assez extrême dans ses prises de
position bien sûr il est très
intéressant et je pense qu'il vaut le
coup d'être vu et d'être discuté ensuite
une les personnages masculins sont assez
terrible et certains de ses personnages
féminins aussi en fait c'est un film qui
parle de la culture du viol du déni face
auxquels peuvent se mettre certains
hommes quand on leur parle de viol et
donc c'est un film qui vaut le coup
d'être vu et je pense que sa prise de
position voilà qui va peut être choquer
certains qui roule alors ça va trop loin
et nécessaire et justement amène à faire
parler il est extrêmement bien
interpréter est beau et il ya des
moments enfin moi j'en suis ressorti
assez écoeuré par ce que il ya des
moments justement beau et l'union et
puis ensuite on s'en prend plein la
gueule et c'était bien avec tous les
tricks gavarnie qu'il faut il fait
évidemment regardez le ensuite on change
encore totalement le sujet puisque j'ai
envie de vous parler de kaamelott alors
je sais pas si vous avez entendu parler
de kaamelott mais je pense que vous avez
entendu par la terre bloque et c'est pas
le film que j'ai préféré de l'année loin
de là il a beaucoup de défauts plus que
les deux films précédents mais c'est un
film quand même qui était déjà très
attendu de la part de beaucoup de femmes
et j'aime beaucoup le camelot sans
tomber dans les extrêmes de matha citer
toutes les répliques des combes le
mentionne la série vous avez envie de le
voir je suis allé voir dès sa sortie et
je vais trouver beaucoup de qualités un
level up certain par rapport à la série
avec encore beaucoup de défauts le
scénario était quand même assez bancale
par moments certains personnages étaient
soit sous-exploité soit trop exploité et
un peu inutiles et lanciaux puisqu'il
est devenu enfin je ne veux pas spoiler
non plus mais il y avait aussi des très
bonnes choses des nouveaux personnages
très bien amené par exemple guillaume
gallienne qui je trouve est est très
très bien dans le début du film et des
personnages qu'on a plaisir à retrouver
ils ont tous évolué un petit peu ça fait
dix ans qu'ils sont là et c'est beau de
voir cette évolution est surtout c'est
un premier volet d'une trilogie qui je
pense est prometteuse parce que voilà ce
premier volet suffit déjà plus tôt à
lui-même est une histoire se termine et
je pense que là dessus pour aller
vraiment bien ou alors c'est pour moi il
vaut le coup d'être vu sans transition
on reste dans le moyen-age fantasmer
puisque j'ai très envie de vous parler
de de greenlight là en fait je vous
parle des films dans leur banque elle je
les ai vus pendant l'année donc de
greenlight j'ai adoré et je sais qu'ils
divisent par ce que pas j'ai des amis
qui m'ont vu qu'ils m'ont dit que
c'était extrêmement mauvais chiant
élitiste au possible et bah je pense pas
parce que je pense pas trop de personnes
élitiste je vois
palette très large de films donc on me
l'a dit mais pour moi c'était magnifique
c'est un film qui nous parle d'une
légende d'un récit médiéval qui celui du
chevalier gauvin donc c'est tirer
vraiment dur histoire médiévale qui a
été adapté par le réalisateur et c'est
très intéressant de lire des articles
qui parlent de ça parce que on voit tout
le travail qui a été fait les références
que vous n'avez pas forcément en voyant
le film et il ya une recherche vraiment
poussé et je trouve ça magnifique le
film est beau aussi la musique c'est ma
musique préférée de l'année d'ailleurs
comme spotify l'a fait son son petit
bilan là bas en fait c'était la musique
de ce type étaient tous et il estime âge
sont magnifiques il ya plein de
symbolique par tous deux femmes pas de
symbolique mais de référence à des
légendes à des choses et
voyez le y dure très dure longtemps et
il est très lent donc je sais qu'il fera
pâle une amie d'unanimité mais
personnellement j'ai trouvé très très
très beau et qui m'a beaucoup fait rêver
ensuite ensuite on va parler de lune va
d'une vous en avez probablement dont tu
parlais aussi et cette année on est sur
des films plutôt gros budget dans mes
films préférés temps j'ai pas vu que ça
mais bon c'est comme ça d'une donc tiré
du livre de frank herbert que j'ai lu je
les lui assez tard j'ai commencé à lire
d'une ya peut-être deux ans et la
gentille automne trois puisque jeudi
d'autres choses entre temps mais les
livres sont formidables de ce que j'en
connais parce qu'il ya toute une
dynamique entre les personnages de non
dit qui est assez bien traité dans le
film et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
beaucoup aimée parce que tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est non verbale il ya
énormément de non verbale dans le film
dans le livre est dans le film aussi
c'était beau c'était a pas eu tellement
déjà de critiques positives sur le film
que je n'ai pas énormément nous en
détailler davantage je pense mais
c'était un mot film qui respecte très
bien le livre et non j'attends la suite
avec impatience parce que je pense
qu'elle sera tout aussi bien et j'espère
qu'il y aura encore d'autres suites que
les livres suivants seront traités parce
que il le mérite on revient sur un film
français plutôt loin à nouveau il ya
beaucoup de vies voulons que cette année
dans ce dont on parle pour être
illusions perdues de balzac
à la comédie humaine de balzac et qui
était très très très très bien c'est un
film où l'on voit pas le temps passer
déjà bien qu'il soit non comme je le dit
et on suit la déchéance de ce jeune
homme qui débarque dans un milieu
parisien il arrive à paris en rêvant de
devenir auteur et en poursuivant aussi
une femme qu'il aime en la suivant et il
se retrouve à bosser dans un torchon
journalistique dans un milieu totalement
cynique désabusée qui fait tout pour se
faire le plus d'argent possible et
atteindre la plus grande renommée le
plus grand pouvoir possible voilà c'est
un film sur 7,4 de pouvoir et de de
renommée sur tout l'est de toutes les
manières imaginables
il se prend à ce jeu il s'y perd et
c'est beau de voir cette chute
progressive qui a annoncé dès le début
c'est très bien joué le soir je crois
que je lui ai déjà dit est très bien
réalisé aussi cette époque dont je
recommande chaudement oh ça vous coûte
chi ensuite qui est un film de ridley
scott ridley scott qui a fait beaucoup
filmé cette année et d'ailleurs je me
rends compte que j'ai pas mis de l'asvel
dans ma liste mais en fait qu'il y aura
du bon peut-être pas ledit film au final
même la pression sur kansas gucci pour
l'instant qui est l'un des films que
j'ai préféré cette année aussi encore un
long film donc mais où j'ai vraiment pas
vu le temps passer qui nous parle du
mariage de maurizio gucci avec patricia
reggiani donc c'est une histoire vraie
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de cette histoire
je vais pas spoiler je sais pas quel
point elle est connue moi j'ai
découverte avec le film non plus c'était
très très bien joué à dan driver était
était magnifique dans ce film et son jeu
changer un petit peu d'habitude pour ça
que je fais remarquer plus
particulièrement parce que il était
adorable en tout cas dans la première
partie lady gaga était formidable pour
dja blé tout à fait du jared leto mais
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait aussi un très
bon travail sur le scénario et sur le
traitement des lumières jungle des
moments pour filmer c'est beau ça et ça
a le mérite d'être remarquée du coup je
trouve que le lescott cette année c'est
très bien remis de ses derniers films
genre est suivie d' alien qui était pas
du tout et elle nous a fait de très très
bonnes choses et insolent gucci leurs
commandes et du coup quand je vais aussi
parler de cela ce duel comme ça un
impromptu qui est le premier film de
ridley scott que j'ai eu cette année en
fait puisqu'il est sorti un petit peu
avant c'est un film qui se passe au
moyen-âge donc avec toutes les petites
approximations historiques qu'on peut
imaginer parce que ça c'est pas non plus
le fort de ridley scott à notre dame de
paris qui est toujours en construction
alors qu'on est à la fin du 14e on te
voit bref sinon à part ça c'est un film
qui parle d'une thématique très
importante puisque on y aborde un viol
qu'il ait eu lieu au monde c'est la
question du film mais justement ce film
nous montre les trois visions des trois
personnages concernés c'est-à-dire la
femme qui suivit le viol le violeur est
l'époux de cette ferme qui devient un
des personnages principaux parce que bon
on va quand même pas trop se soucier de
sa parole à est donc c'est très très
bien traitée injustement en divisant
film en trois parties avec ces trois
points de vue et ça montre bien la
situation des femmes à cette époque la
manière aussi dont la justice était
rendue puisque contrairement à ce que
petites rentes x s'agit pas du dernier
duel mais de l'un des derniers duels
judiciaire qui est autre chose que de
personnes qui se croisent qui
s'engueulent et qui se disent ok on
provoque en duel devant on s agit d'un
duel judiciaire dont qui répond à des
règles précises et qui sont assez bien
expliquée dans ce film aussi va tout la
vision du viol la vision des femmes à
l'époque et très bien amené et tout cela
en fait donc un beau film avec parfois
quand même un petit peu longueur
justement à cause du fait que ces
traités en trois parties mais là encore
ça va chose intéressante par exemple on
revoit certaines scènes mais comme elles
sont pas du même point de vue c'est même
pas les mêmes dialogues en fait parce
que ils se souviennent pas de la même
chose les gens et ça j'ai trouvé ça bien
ensuite avant dernier film de cette
sélection la sonatine sow qui est un
film anglais dont le scénario
m'intriguait beaucoup quand j'avais vu
la bande annonce et quand j'avais lu le
synopsis et qui aurait pu être mieux je
m'attendais à un peu mieux je pense
justement à cause de la crise ce que
j'avais vu en envoyant de la bande
annonce mais qui était quand même très
bien donc on y suit une jeune fille qui
débarque dans le milieu de la couture
londonien et qui se retrouve plongée
dans les années 60 voilà une petite part
fantastique mais c'est aussi beaucoup
dans le fantasme de cette jeune fille
donc il se retrouve embarqué dans des
histoires beaucoup plus glauque que
celle qu'elle vit habituellement à cause
justement de ce parallèle entre stable
qui sont d'époque et les années 60 et il
y avait de très bonne musique ensuite
c'était très bien jouer parmi eux john
est toujours aussi magnifique évidemment
je le recommande parce que bailly mes
réponses face son avis dessus la fin
était un peu décevante aussi donc voilà
c'est pas un des films préférés de
l'année par ses dents mais j'ai préféré
n'est ce pas votre père est de l'année
mais je pense qu'ils méritent d'être
mieux c'est très confus ce résumé là
j'ai l'impression de toute la sélection
là j'ai l'impression que c'est bien
résumé mais robert 2 et enfin je termine
avec d'un des derniers films que j'ai
vus cette année et pense surtout le
dernier film qui m'a plu cette année la
fracture on retourne donc sur un film
français qui
m'avait l'air d'être une comédie quand
j'ai vu la bande annonce je me suis dit
c'est ça ma drôle peut-être surnombre
pour l'art ce serait une petite comédie
tranquille mais non vous vous en
prendrez plein la gueule et vous allez
pleurer probablement en tout cas j'ai
pleuré donc c'est un film qui se passe
au moment des manifs des gilet jaune on
y suit plein d'histoires en parallèle
mais principalement un couple qui sur le
point de se séparer mais dont on s'est
un peu de femmes est l'une des femmes se
pète la gueule et donc se retrouvent aux
urgences et des manifestants des gilets
jaunes notamment l'un des personnages
qui lui est blessé lors d'une manif est
ce qu'on trouve aussi aux urgences et au
tour de david plaintes ont enfin on suit
une nuit aux urgences en plein berlin dg
les jeunes avec tous les problèmes qu'on
connaît dans les hôpitaux de nos jours
et qui ont été bien amplifié depuis
merci le cofide il ya beaucoup de
moments drôles mais c'est aussi terrible
est-ce que tout fout le camp
littéralement et à un moment il ya un
bout de plafond qui s'effondre sur l'un
des gars qui attendent urgence et
personnes panique dans le personnel se
disant ok bon on va appeler quelqu'un
normal c'était normal donc ça en fait un
film que j'ai trouvé assez magnifique et
très bien traité et voilà qui mêle très
bien le drôle ou à tout le bloc de cette
situation et la tristesse de ce monde
qui parle plus et c'est là dessus que je
termine ce avec appétit natif des films
de 2021 en vous souhaitant une très
bonne fin d'année
voilà j'espère que ça vous donnera envie
de voir ses films j'en ai vu beaucoup
d'autres femmes du progrès vont remettre
comme d'habitude une petit récap de tous
les films que j'ai vus avec ce que j'ai
aimé pas aimé l'apprendre vidéo j'ai un
petit peu de couleur à chaque fois avec
les films vert foncé sept top ouvert
moyens jaune orange rouge rouge c'est
vraiment pas cool du tout et donc là bas
je vous ai cité des films qui étaient
soit vert foncé sinon donc là je
m'apprête à aller fêter noël mais vous
en hiver vidéo doit elle sera déjà passé
et où seraient en route vers le nouvel
an et donc je vous souhaite de très
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année en espérant
que vous puissiez les fêter moi par
exemple on sera en petit comité non plus
à cause des restrictions mais à cause
des gens pour choper pau ville mais
c'est comme ça si vous êtes confinait
s'il disait tu poses idées ou malades de
quelques manières que ce soit je vous
souhaite un très bon rétablissement
aussi et sinon pour parler un petit peu
de la chaîne j'ai sorti beaucoup moins
deux vidéos durant cet automne j'ai
sorti un jean todt i'm bad ass et j'ai
toujours un produit de france dans les
recherches sont terminées mais que je
peine réellement à écrire et du coup
c'est un peu en pause ça ne veut pas
dire que j'arrête du tout j'ai toujours
envie de faire ça mais j'ai aussi
toujours envie que ça reste un loisir
sur tout et donc la jeune fille un peu
trop mis la pression ces derniers mois
en ce sens il faut que je sorte une
vidéo tu sortes une vidéo et et ça va un
peu bloquée je pense que c'est surtout
ça qui va bloquer donc là je prends le
temps de d'avoir à nouveau ce désir de
la sortir parce que sinon ça va devenir
une corvée et ça reste un loisir pour
moi très légèrement rémunérés mais avant
tout une activité une passion à la base
et donc j'ai envie que ça reste une
passion et si je veux continuer à faire
des vidéos il faut qu'on reste aux
nations donc je pense que je les sortira
nous invente dame badass en début
d'année et puis il prend le temps de me
remettre à l'écriture de ce chronique de
profs parce que si j'écris énormément en
ce moment à côté je continue d'avancer
sur mon prochain livre d'histoire mais
aussi j'ai écrit un roman qui encourt de
finges en train de terminer d'écrire un
roman que j'ai commencé en novembre
c'est quand même un truc qui prend un
petit peu de temps et j'ai écrit une
pièce de théâtre aussi s'en faire une
fête format le jour sur la route j'ai
écrit une pièce de théâtre donc j'écris
beaucoup et pas ça fait que lentement
pour faire autre chose de ces journées
une fois qu'on a terminé les clercs pas
et j'ai aussi à tourner ma première
mission pour médiévale tv qui sortira en
janvier donc sa medi 1 tv c'est une
plateforme de streaming payant si on
allait là suivait l'histoire et qu'ils
proposent mais dépend des émissions sur
le moyen-âge et donc moi je fais les
missions de l'institution chez eux et on
va tourner premier épisode qui s'était
super bien donc si vous êtes abonné
j'espère que vous les vrais si vous
n'êtes pas abonné banquiers pensent
peut-être le moment de le faire
puisqu'il ya déjà certaines émissions
qui sont sortis la chaîne est sorti le 2
décembre elle a été lancée le 2 décembre
donc voilà je vous recommande ça parce
que ce que j'ai vu des premières
émissions ça a l'air vraiment qualitatif
et voilà je pense que j'ai fait le tour
de ce que j'avais à vous raconter et me
reste maintenant à vous souhaiter de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année avant que 20
mois de 17 donc là que j'ai cogité juste
beaucoup parler la poudre
je vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année si vous faites la fête et si
vous ne le faites pas vous pourrez pas
faire je vous souhaite dans tous les cas
une très bonne journée voilà et notre
bonne journée dans la vie et à bientôt
donc pour de prochaines vidéos
l'histoire merci beaucoup
[Musique]